a man known for his divisive political
views Nigel farage is back in the
headlines
but this time it's his finances that
have got people talking
the former ukip leader has claimed the
exclusive Bank Coots has closed his
account due to his political status as a
politically exposed person that is now
nine other banks that have refused me
they're telling the Press I don't meet
their wealth threshold well they'd never
mentioned that before in the previous 10
years the worst of a story is they
denied to me on the phone on Friday that
I was a pep a politically exposed person
that's the reason nobody else will have
me and Coots are frankly being very very
dishonest
Sky News contacted Coots for comment and
they directed us to their website which
reads clients are required to maintain
at least one million pounds in
Investments or borrowing mortgage or 3
million pounds in savings
Coots also explains it takes into
account commercial viability legal or
regulatory requirements and reputation
claiming the bank's actions are
politically motivated farage has failed
to deny that he has too few funds in his
account to remain eligible at a time
when Banks and the financial sector are
already in the firing line over
allegations of profiteering regarding
interest rates questions around whether
banks are targeting their clients
because of their political views will do
nothing to enamor the sector to the
public
Rishi sunak and Nigel farage have not
been the most obvious political
bedfellows but today the Prime Minister
weighed into the debate the chancellor
has been very clear about this and
spoken to The Regulators obviously we
have to respect people's right to free
speech and that should not be an excuse
to close anyone's account and that's not
what we would expect
he's known for his often controversial
views but he claims he's now being
targeted for them Mari Aurora Sky News